The Proposal then comes the planning if
they said yes right hopefully fingers
crossed if they said yes that we have a
very special author and lifestyle expert
here Amy LaBelle I am so excited to talk
to you look at this beautiful spread
first and foremost you know what you're
doing now you have you have a book out
called wine weddings yes it's all about
DIY outlining wine themed weddings what
is a wine themed wedding oh wine themed
weddings are the thing for 2023. okay so
I've hosted over a thousand weddings at
the winery that I own LaBelle Winery up
in New England and because of that we
have a lot of experience working with
couples and trying to take some of the
stress out of the big day you know it
can be a lot of pressure a lot of stress
absolutely so I wanted to write a book
that was a guide that would help people
take some of that road map and just lay
it out for them and our idea is that it
should be a wine theme to guide you ever
seen pictures is this your Winery yes it
is oh my God and that's my wedding
look how beautiful okay now I want to I
want to give you a shout out personally
because you said four percent of wine
makers yes are women four percent of the
world's wine is it four percent of the
world's wine makers are women and you
are part of that yes ma'am I am a woman
winemaker that is huge so what is give
us some of your best tips you know
within your book that you could give us
that we have here yeah so you know the
book is all about creating that magical
moment and those special events and of
course the book is focused on Weddings
But we all have a lot of big events
coming up here for the holidays so we're
gonna make some cocktails oh I love it
and I want to take some stress out of
holiday planning for people too I mean
we do events every day at the winery so
this is yeah right we said other than
author and you know winemaker it's
lifestyle expert so you know what you're
doing well we throw a lot of events and
I love to put wine in all of my recipes
so and that makes it all so delicious in
layers and layers of flavor and it's
good everybody loves it so here
absolutely we cook with mine all the
time absolutely right now we have 45
seconds so let's get to let's do it this
is a this is a gingerbread White Russian
we're bringing back the White Russian so
if you want to put all these ingredients
in this cocktail shaker let's do it and
we're I rimmed it with some gingerbread
and molasses molasses gives this a
really great deep flavor while you're
doing that I'm gonna work on this just
trying to get them last time there's
gonna be a problem but it's in there
guys
we got 30 seconds this is a bourbon
French 75 French 75 is usually made with
vodka or gin we make it with our
sparkling Shimmer this is a wine I make
at the winery and I love bourbon so I
like to deal with bourbon oh that's a
bourbon some Bitters and then we top
that with some lemon simple syrup just a
little bit and we topped it the best
part always celebrating with champagne
and then while I take a sip of that
let's enjoy oysters okay
oysters you want to put wine in your
cooking because it makes your food so
much it makes your food delicious so
what we've done is a wine based
minionette and a wine infused cocktail
sauce you don't have to beat a technical
expert to make this go on my website
amylabelle.com and I'll help you get
your holidays worked right out wow well
congratulations on all your success
thank you Hawaiian weddings new book out
so go get where can we get it Amazon
Barnes Noble or my website simple as
that easy thank you Amy JC Austin to you